joining me today as a sociologist a
physician a professor at Yale University
and author of the new book blueprint the
evolutionary origins of a good society
Nick Christakis welcome to the Rubin
report thank you for having me dude I am
happy to have you here sir but I'm
depressed that I have to start the show
the way I sword I have to start the show
yeah inspect you know how I have to
start the show yeah so you want to set
it up for me well I mean we do just have
to get this out I know I know I mean I
knew when the book was published I mean
I've been working in the book for nine
years and I knew when it was published
that I would have to revisit those
events from 2015 which you know we're
just a challenging period of my life
thankfully in the past I'm really glad
to have it behind me yeah but I
recognized that so you tell whatever
part of it you want to tell okay so you
are and were a professor at Yale yes
this is this isn't I think the fall of
2015
yes fall of 2015 and your wife Erica
who's also a professor childhood
development
she was an instructor but yes she
basically wrote a piece that said it was
a defense of free speech and it was sort
of worked around the Halloween costume
idea that you know you should wear what
you want but you can try to be
respectful of people but you know we
shouldn't have some sort of top-down
version where people you know
administrators or professors or telling
students what to wear you offered her a
bit of a defense on that and now all
throw to the clip is that fair fair okay
let's throw to the clip don't need to
bend down I'm not bending what's your
name I do not respect you hear that I'm
looking at the smirk on your face like
I'm disgusted okay I'm sick and I'm sick
watching them argue with you after we've
been standing outside literally for at
least five to six hours between you and
Holloway between last night to now we've
been arguing with people who are not
willing to be listened to for a long
time and all I see from you is arrogance
and ego
I am sick looking at you I am disgusted
watching elects argue with you you were
not listening you were disgusting I
don't think you understand that and if
before I wasn't I before I was not angry
per se I was disappointed maybe I
thought maybe there was room for it
before an apology you've clearly told us
that you do not plan to offer an apology
for your words you left the meeting last
night to go home and then tweet do not
interrupt me to tweets from your Twitter
and then the filaments Twitter you
showed no remorse you tried to let your
wife believe that conversation without
having answered for herself that is
disgusting
that is sick and now I wasn't angry
before and was not angry before but now
I am actually angry sir I really do not
interrupt me I was not angry and now I
want your job to be taken from you I
don't want you to have this job I am
disgusted knowing that you work at Yale
University where I will get my degree
where I will look back and think I have
to argue with you don't do it don't do
it sir do not do it this is not the day
you do not want to play this game with
me do something you know what whose game
with me okay understand that look at me
in my face first of all and understand
that you are such a disappointment to
this University to your students to
yourself the things that you cling to
agree with you were you want free dialog
you want free speech this is how it
works someone speaks you listen you
don't cut them off you do not do these
these condescending gestures you do not
smirk you look them in the face and you
wait you wait until it is your turn okay
so before we even dive into that the
second we played the clip you let out a
big exhale it was interested in this
anymore
yeah it's depressing to look back both
are true it's you know it's I was in the
courtyard for two hours and 15 minutes
from 4:00 to 6:00 15 about an hour of
footage has been released of from five
or six different vantage points you
showed one clip that's typically not the
clip that's shown so many people put
stuff online you can reap you can piece
together the whole hour between 5 & 6
for the first hour that I was out in the
courtyard I listened quietly to the
students you know there's a lot of stuff
that that young woman said that's just
factually wrong she's alluding to an
event that occurred the night before at
the Africa afro-american cultural house
at Yale where there was a huge event
with hundreds of students it had been
announced at the beginning that we would
have to leave that event at the
conclusion it was I can't remember the
precise timing but I think it was
scheduled from 6:00 to 8:00 my wife had
to teach a class from 7:00 to 9:00 so
she'd in the evening so she told her
students she'd be late and we'd stay
from 6:00 to 8:00 she did in fact speak
to the crowd she had to leave to teach
and I we had a student in the hospital
actually that evening that I was
responsible for and that also was known
so so when she said that we tried to
leave that's not that's false you know I
think that many of the students were
swept up in a kind of a mob fervor I
think they behaved badly they should
have known better I think they were
trying to assert power if I had a tool
when I was that age that could get
grown-ups into trouble right you know
probably I would just kept doing it
non-stop and they had found a tool yes
yes yes and and so but so I think what
distressed me is I think at some point
in the background of that footage that
one of the administrators actually the
author what happened is is a man by the
name of Birdwell Howard had moved from
North Western University to Yale and had
assumed a new position there and he had
written an email he had written an a
memo while at Northwestern admonishing
students not to wear offensive costumes
and I should say for the record that
many of the students that many of the
costumes that he or anyone else would
find offensive I too would find
offensive I wouldn't like these costumes
I'm well aware of the long history of
racism in our society I'm well aware of
the ways in which there's trafficking
and certain cultural tropes that put
down other groups I reject I am of I
have a very Pro immigrant policy I
belief system i i i think that anyone
can be an american i love the idea that
we have open borders you know i mean i
have a set of beliefs that are around
openness and welcoming you're a lefty
yeah i am quite a let I am a lefty I'm
left of center play I mean I have some
conservative ideas some libertarian I I
think of myself as a classical liberal
and I think of myself as very pragmatic
in policymaking so I like I like markets
to address most allocation of goods but
I also very concerned about market
failures and then I want government
intervention anyway so so so that anyway
that man who was a then had moved to
Yale and then he took out of mothballs
this email that he had sent at
Northwestern five or ten years earlier
got a bunch of Yale administrators to
sign it and then send it off and in it
he had links to approved and non
approved costumes the very costumes
which were deemed to be offensive in his
email there were links to lots of those
ostensibly offensive costumes and the
students there had been a lot of
conversation at the time the New York
Times had a big piece like the previous
month about the growing use of Halloween
costume advice at American colleges so
it was in the zeitgeist this was the
third his email was the third email that
had been sent out telling students
giving them advice so in my wife's class
many of the students in the class and
other students in the college where we
the sub part of Yale that we were
responsible for had told her that they
felt this was very infantilizing and
they didn't really need advice on what
to wear and so my wife from a
developmental perspective wrote a
response to this email which itself had
been was signed by 13 administrators it
it didn't it was framed as guidance but
it sort of had the color of law and so
she wrote a response saying and her
intellectual point was not where
whatever you want right her intellectual
point was do use students at Yale in
your 20s early to knit late teens early
20s really need older adults to tell you
what to wear provide you guidance you
should think about that and decide
whether you really and apparently many
students didn't want such guidance and
so then I was then thereafter there all
hell broke loose and I was in a
courtyard and did the best I could yeah
what do you make of the reason we chose
that cliff
because there is the other more famous
clip of the girl Lily berating you in
there were many many that were done I
heard that that was the one that I think
we note here and that I think that's the
most violent but I thought that one was
interesting because the angle was a
little different and you could see some
of the other kids and and the you know
the tears or the look of horror or all
of these things when you actually didn't
do anything yes well that's another
whole topic I think that I mean many
people have analyzed those events and
honestly I don't I don't know if I have
anything to add to those analyses I
think that the the thing that was very
interesting to me so so one of the ideas
that I've been thinking about for a long
time is this tension between our
individuality and our group business and
we have evolved - first of all it's a
very interesting idea we've evolved to
be individuals so we humans have unique
identities so we have unique faces so
you can look at a sea of people and can
tell who's who and not only do we have
the ability to signal our uniqueness you
we use our faces for that but we have
the cognitive apparatus to detect that
uniqueness so you you can have a lot of
brain power you haven't done you
allocate to tell who's ooh so this
ability to be individuals is crucial for
our ability to function in groups it's
very paradoxical because you need that
capacity to tell who is my offspring
who's my friend who do i reciprocate
kindness to who do i cooperate with
who's my enemy all of these things so
all of these capacities of individuality
are crucial to our collective expression
our ability to live together but equally
we we have this desire to surrender
ourselves to the group to do something
called 2d individuate to form a part of
a collectivity to suppress our
individual desires which also allows us
to work together but the irony is when
you get too much of that you get mobs
you get panics you get you know all
kinds of collective phenomena that are
destructive rather than constructive so
when I was in the the crowd when I was
in that mob I I knew what was happening
I could tell so one of the things I
started doing was is I started asking
people what's your name mm-hmm
and I was trying to connect to them
person-to-person saying you know hi I'm
Nicolas who are you so you're a person
and I'm a person you're not a part of
this a mob you are a human being and I'm
a human being and in fact the one thing
that happened that that isn't is an
intellectual idea that's part of this
book that I've been working on for 10
years but that's also I made in the heat
of the moment is in the moment I said to
the students I said that I believe in
our common humanity I believe that even
though this person and this person is
superficially different than me
nevertheless we can talk to each other
we all have life experiences we're human
beings and end it and then if you if you
don't believe that if you don't believe
we have a common humanity which I see as
a wonderful thing yeah optimist if you
don't believe in our common humanity why
are you even trying to talk to me and
the students jeered yeah they jeered
it's on film they jeered and I honestly
I think that's one of the most
depressing things that's happened that
I've ever seen actually said the Yale
students in the 21st century would jeer
at what I regard to be a fundamental
humane wonderful claim about human
beings is that we have a common humanity
so all right so I know you don't want to
spend the whole time I don't but I do
but I think a lot of this does segue to
your book reasons that you just laid out
so I was trying to do that here's a
tidbit CPI watch what I'm gonna get but
that look that you're talking about when
you say that like we have been able to
share yeah I'm in humanity I've been
there too I mean I face these mobs and
what I find is there there's an actual
look they haven't yes we're the
individual that you just spoke about is
gone yes yes did you think there was
anything so I guess there's really in
that case for the people that are
watching this that think that one day
they're gonna go against the mob is
there any other advice you would have
for them on how to how to do it because
I know I always work I mean saying I've
done that where I've said I'm standing
right in for and listening to yes my
name is Dave yes
and it done I think that
I I don't know III I don't know you know
there's that there's that scene in Lord
of the Rings where Aragorn rushes the
gates you know and of Mordor and I of
course love those movies and you know I
don't know if I would have I don't think
I don't know if I would be capable of
such bravery but intellectually I
definitely a.m. that is to say I'm not
easily cloud and I spent my life
training myself to think as clearly as I
can to look at evidence to collect
evidence I'm an obscene 'test I'm an
empiricist so so in the in the case of a
mob I don't think I would yield to a mob
intellectually now physically you know
if they're if they're throwing bricks at
you is a different thing right but I
think you often that threat is always
there even if they're not holding a
weapon yeah it's right under it's a
dangerous situation I would agree but
mass you know movements are always
dangerous but my point is that I think
that if you if you can keep your calm
you can think clearly about what you're
saying also if you've thought about
these ideas before in the cool of the
day so it's not the heat at the moment
said like I've really thought about
these ideas this is not just a sudden
heat of passion like I thought about
this topic or at this point whatever it
is it doesn't have to be a political
point it can be scientific point or
something then when you're pressed you
know you can say you know I'm listening
to you here's what I think okay what do
you think I think you can I think you
can you can I won't say you can win the
panel ideas but you can at least fight
it well yeah what was the
administration's response after this
well I think the administration faced a
difficult challenge in deciding what to
do many people have commented on what
they did or didn't do I'm not sure I
want to go into it it took them quite a
while to come to to release any kind of
public statement in support of us so and
you know many members of the
administration junior members were
actually involved in so in the crowd
that day there were four for
administrators actually who you know
whose others have since identified but
you know I think I don't think
it was Yale at its best and and I don't
and the students were not at their best
and and I was not at my best I did my
best but you know I think I could have
done even better so as someone that then
has lived through it where did this go
wrong on college campuses because for
the past couple years every time I see
one of these stories I think either well
I used to think oh this will this is the
end of it now people will really get it
like I remember you're the one with you
from the other video clip that we didn't
show that people had seen it was like
this is so patently absurd maybe this
will finally be the wake-up call I've
now come to believe that the wake up
call is in coming anytime soon
sadly but what when do you think as well
I think this is a complicated topic I
see you know this is not was not my area
of expertise I am a natural and social
scientist I run a lab with computer
scientists and molecular biologists and
sociologists and evolutionary biologists
and we work around the world we do all
kinds of stuff so I I was I have always
been committed to liberal principles
including to free speech when when I was
at Harvard before I moved to Yale in
2013 my wife and I came to the defense
of minority students who were being
having their write their speech rights
squelched on campus so it's I'm
committed to these ideas but it wasn't
like the most central part of my life
and I'm not an expert like John Hyde or
Greg lucky off luciano far however so I
see conflicting evidence I agree with
you that there are a lot of these
salient cases which which they weren't
before and Jonathan feels that they're
still rising and they have their own
theories Jonathan and Greg about why I
see other evidence that looks at surveys
of college students and finds that they
are no more or less likely to want to
suppress the speech of others than
adults than older adults it's very
tempting to silence people who don't
agree with right I mean everyone wants
to do that no I don't I want to talk to
them and persuade them like you know it
would be it would be very tempting to
like you know shut the anti-vaxxers up
you know prevent them from speaking but
that doesn't win right that that's not a
victory what we need to do is persuade
them why do you believe think this so so
if you compare college students adults
some evidence suggests they're not more
sanctimonious um
evidence suggests there are some polls
if you look at dis invitations they're
clearly rising but they're still small
so so the critics say there's a rising
level of dissing vacations which I
deplore let me just can I go on a
digression yeah yes so I have no let me
very clear because there's a lot of
sloppy thinking about this nobody has a
right to speak on a college campus so
I'm not claiming that anyone has a right
but once a group on campus right invites
you to speak
you cannot yield to the mob for a dis
invitation it totally destroys the
university it's it's the antithesis of
what our university should be like so
you can protest that person but you
cannot have dis invitations that's just
ridiculous
so so there so those have been rising
but so the critics say look this
invitation oven rising but the
defendants a guess but millions of talks
take place and nobody objects so it's a
tiny minority so to answer your question
I don't I don't think we're beyond the
hump but I'm not the expert to tell you
how bad is it does it say something
about the state of liberalism or in a
way that that this was sort of the end
conclusion of liberalism I hate to say
it that it would get sort of usurped by
progressivism or whatever the new
collectivist idea was in other words
liberals are tolerant liberals generally
or live-and-let-live so it was sort of
fertile ground for people with bad ideas
to rush in and kind of take over where
perhaps conservatives are a little
harder to get in at because there it is
yeah yeah but conservatives have their
own political failings right never doubt
yeah they'll move in lockstep so you can
get them to like you know you to to mark
to get to get to organize an inquisition
right so you know it's not like right we
get there it's not comparing either
right and I'm just saying that there's
there there's something a weakness of
nihilism which is very sad for me to say
the openness is exactly what invites
yeah so this is radicalism within yeah
so I mean I think this is I mean I think
you know the open society and its and
its enemies you know I think there is a
sense in which you can use the tools to
destroy the foundation but I also think
and this is one of
the arguments that I made and I actually
believe politically which is that these
very core commitments to freedom of
assembly freedom of expression which the
students were using right now
now we're also engaging in harassment
yeah which is a different topic and you
because I was an actor in those events I
I was was I didn't feel at liberty to
help the students see the difference
between freedom of expression and
harassment right yeah somehow I don't
think they would have been like oh let's
sit down and listen to him as you
explain it explains why you know so you
can so the classic example is the you
know is that you know you can you can
march through the streets of Skokie
Illinois but you can't stop in front of
my house right right because you know
that is a threat the political
expression in a public place is not so
so so the students so there's so I lost
my train of thought or was I going well
basically the idea that the liberalism
and that yeah so so these are core that
sort of non corrupt judiciary sort
impartial separation of powers a freedom
of assembly freedom of speech I regard
these as like foundational principles of
our democracy which are central liberal
principles which the students in some
ways we're using right except to call
for people to be fired for expressing
their ideas on a college campus is using
these principles but to illiberal ends
and this is what you're asking I think
which is what you're saying is can these
tools be used to like degrade the and
and the answer is yes there is a kind of
threat from within but I still wouldn't
abandon the principles and I don't want
to abandon the penis Lizzie there okay
there we go
[Music]